mars were from the viking landers
now how does that compare with what
you're seeing now
yeah so you know the the first
successful landing on mars back in
1976 and the two viking landers one and
two
set down on the surface and very
different camera systems than
we use today but for the time they were
you know designed and built in the early
1970s they were just
incredibly cutting edge incredibly state
of the art
but also very very simple compared to
today's cameras
the viking cameras had basically single
detectors and they were scanned
up and down and then moving along the
side kind of like a fax machine almost
and so i remember being a kid watching
on the nightly news
the first pictures coming down from mars
and they were coming down in these
little strips like
you know and it was like watching paint
drip down the wall
and a little bit at a time and it took
hours you know and and you see oh
there's the foot pad you know
it was incredibly exciting of course the
first time we got down onto mars
nowadays we're used to digital cameras
and our cell phones or dls dslrs
uh we're used to big arrays of pixels
megapixel arrays
and so you know mass cam z is a two
megapixel camera which is
pretty good for space there are higher
megapixel cameras on this rover but
for us it does the job and its
resolution
varies because of course we go wide
angle all the way to telephoto
in stereo with those two eyes here
you're seeing in this next graphic the
two eyes of
mass cam z up on the mast and that mass
can let us move around
360 degrees up and down
and that's how we build panoramas and
you'll you'll hear more about that from
from elsa at the widest setting we got
about two and a half times better
resolution than those viking cameras and
at the telephoto setting we got about 10
times better resolution
than those viking cameras so those are a
great
start to the legacy of of imaging on
mars that we're
we're picking up with this mission
and what an amazing opportunity jim for
you to be able to watch that growth
this is your fifth mars landing and to
be able to watch
just exponentially how these cameras
have gotten better and better so
what kind of advice do you have for the
future scientists and engineers watching
today on
what they will bring perhaps the table
coming up
yeah you know uh you've got a lot of uh
young young people and early career
people here at asu
uh working with us faculty staff
students we have
i'm in the mission operations center for
mass camzy here at asu on the tempe
campus and
uh so we do a lot of the processing here
and i think what's happening is you know
these
students we work with and others they're
seeing the future of deep space imaging
these video cameras with these higher
and higher megapixel
capabilities with more infrastructure
out in the solar system to get
the data back you know we we can talk
about bandwidth and how
you know we can take megapixels and
movies and all kinds of stuff but we
don't have high-speed internet to mars
right we have
basically the equivalent of old-style up
so
that's a you know advancing that
frontier we're seeing incredible
improvements
uh in our mission compared to previous
ones and how we can get
all those pixels into the tiny straw of
bandwidth getting back to the earth
so i think that's just going to continue
to improve and we'll continue to send
amazing missions out there and the
instruments are going to get more and
more sophisticated basically following
the you know consumer electronics and
all the great amazing things that are
happening
in digital imaging in our everyday lives
so much to look forward to as we look
into the future and
speaking of that you said it's been a
feast for the eyes i don't think we
could ever get enough of that so moving
over to elsa
elsa how do we actually take these
pictures on mars
um you know it's it's amazing actually
we started two years ago
and if i could have the mosaic image
number three
number three please it it actually
from start to finish to take a picture
like this in the box
is about two years it's taken a core
team of six
people starting two years ago to plan
test and execute over 5
000 command parameters that go into this
image
and we we took it only three years after
landing
which in mars time mars mission time is
just a blink of an eye
you know you land and we already have to
execute it
so we had to start a long time ago you
know it's um
funny because when you take a panamera
like this on mars you
you think you know it's very technical
and it is but it's
in some ways the same as when you have
your smartphone
because what you need to do is you have
to look in the right direction
and you have to get the focus right and
that's really what we focus
on um when we're taking these images
we're millions of miles away though our
selfie stick if you will is 150 million
miles long so when we take the pictures
we can't just go out and do it and when
we press the shutter button hey
take a picture it takes a day for the
signal to get to mars
and it takes another day before we get
the images back
so we have that challenge of time and
space if you will
um so how do we how do we do that then
um we use our experience
um we've been doing this for a long time
we've actually been imaging
um for eight years with curiosity
with the mast cam and that has led to a
ton of experience
we use our intuition
and then we have computer tools and
um as we put all these things together
we
we make a draft we test it we
get results some of them work some women
don't and then we test again
so i wanted to um introduce one of the
most important tools that we've used in
creating mosaics which is the command
visualization tool called viewpoint
it was developed by one of our team
members john proton
and it provides us with um a way to
visualize
as if we were on mars looking at the
mars images behind it and the computer
uh model of the rover um and then we can
lay down
footprints um and that's a great way to
pretend that we've that we're right
there with masscam as you saw the
pictures before we're right there with
mastcam
taking the images um and
be able to visualize that so
if i could have the next picture please
thank you you see here the frames see
all the red
squares the red rectangles that's
actually the footprints that we've laid
down
um for this mosaic and there's 142 total
like i mentioned before there's 50
over 5000 commands for all together to
take these 142 images that we stitched
together
now in this case we didn't land on mars
before we took this right we had to plan
it in the blind
so we had to um start with
our information that we had available
which was from curiosity
so two years ago two of our office
engineers at the time jason manbike and
tex kobachky
put together kind of a draft and then
that sequence we took into testing with
the thermal vacuum chamber
which is house size so imagine a small
house
that is in mars conditions with the
temperatures fluctuating about 100
degrees between day and night
and also some of the air pumped out for
vacuum
and we tested in there and then um
we also got special permission to
execute
this um sequence at kennedy space center
and that was important because of the
focus
um we could get the landscape pretty
well from curiosity
but we also needed information on how to
focus on the various details of the
perseverance rover deck because that's
different than curiosity
so uh we got that in the bag
um and thank goodness because that's
what allowed us to put the
sequence together all all of it in um
in one sequence we sent it up two weeks
before we actually landed
on mars um we do that to ensure that
um as a mitigation case the
communication errors right after we land
it was all fine but in case we would
have it on board already and ready to
execute when we landed
so that's part of the the thorough
testing that we do
um when we're preparing to go to mars
so i got finally with
all of that we had our cognizant
engineer mike kaplan here at msq
we had ops engineers tex and angela
and chris and myself we checked and
reject and then we were ready to fly
so if i could have the next the next
image please
here's how we laid out the panorama you
see how we start at the horizon
where imagine being on the mast you're
looking one way
and then looking next down then down we
go
as we take the panorama and building
up tile by tile from the horizon and all
the way down to the rover deck
142 different frames you can see we have
focus on the hardware
on the landscape and it's all put
together into one sequence
so it's great to be here today our team
is loving being on mars
we're taking already hundreds and
hundreds of images with this camera and
we're gonna take
thousands tens if not hundreds of
thousands in the future
we're so happy to be here from male and
space science systems
and love working with jim and asu thank
you for having us come along to mars
again and uh we just cannot wait to get
going with this camera thank you
awesome thank you so much elsa such
great information and that was such an
incredible animation there
as well and it obviously takes a village
to get all of these images processed and
put out to the public
and kiarten what's a calibration target
and why do you actually need one
so all all scientific instruments
basically need some sort of calibration
you need to
to make sure by by imaging or measuring
some standard something that you know
really well you need to make sure
exactly how
the readings of your instrument
translate to things in the real world
and we went through a lot of pre-flight
calibration a lot of activities to
to image lamps and and and
dot patterns and other things with the
cameras to make sure that we understood
these instruments really well
and a lot of the instruments also have
calibration targets
on board the rover that they can visit
and we have a calibration target that we
can image
to check that things are still operating
as they should but our calibration
target actually kind of has a purpose
that goes a little bit beyond that um
and the reason is
um the mask mc is a color camera of
course it it
acquires color images in red green and
blue but it also has a whole set of
of a special optical filters what we
call narrow band filters that are
basically filters that
image at sort of tightly around us a
single frequency a wavelength of light
um and we have 11 different of them from
a little bit into the ultraviolet a
little bit out into the
infrared and with all of these different
14 11 narrow and and three red green and
blue with all these 14
color bands and we can we can make some
some color images that allow us to go a
little bit beyond
human vision and and tease out
differences in the terrain
tell one rock from another or tell that
two rocks are
similar um or tell layering
in in a cliff phase or or or what have
you and also on things that might not be
visible to the to the human eye to
standard red green and blue
um but when you look at at a rock
on mars or a rock on earth or anything
you're seeing a color that's a
combination of
the color of the light and the color of
the thing the rock
and so you know you know if you light
shine red light on a
on a on something it looks red and you
shine blue light on it it looks blue
and on mars the illumination will change
like it does on earth you know
sun may be high in the sky maybe low in
the sky if the
atmosphere may be dusty it may be not so
dirty so it will change over time and it
changes on fairly
short time skills and it's kind of hard
to model um
and uh so for that we use the
calibration target and can i get
slide number number seven into
calibration target
um so that's a uh just a little aluminum
plate
with uh some patches uh ceramic patches
in four colors and four gray scales and
four rings and the same gray scales
um and these are our colors and gray
scales that we had
we characterized super well before we
flew to mars so we know exactly how they
reflect light and so
so imaging this with the camera allows
the camera actually to measure the
illumination measure the light that
comes in
and then we take a picture of mars and
then we can use that information
to basically divide out that
illumination and we can then convert the
image of mars
to what we call a reflectance calibrated
image and that's an image that shows
the um the inherent color
of the rocks and the soil how they
reflect light
rather than the illumination and that
way you can compare them to
images you took 10 days back when the
atmosphere was dustier
or image you have of iraq in your
laboratory or
or whatever and that helps the the
science team use the camera to
pick out interesting targets and so on
if you if you give me the next slide
um it's a it's a close-up of this
calibration
target um and we're going to be imaging
it a lot and so we added some
some decorations and a little model
to it um and it's just been an amazing
journey
seeing it for the first time on the
surface of mars was
amazing i'm sitting here and it's 10 p.m
in
in central copenhagen in the nilspor
institute i'm actually
sitting in milspor's old office he was
one of the fathers of modern physics and
they let me sit in his office they left
it preserved since he passed away in 62
and and and everybody here that has
worked on this project
are have just been so excited to be able
to contribute to this amazing mission
and be a part of this amazing team
caroten amazing information here and i
actually have a social media question
that's coming in that really pertains to
what you were just talking about
joshua becomes on twitter says this is
really incredible to see i'm sure we all
think that
now are these photos artificially
colored
no i mean i don't i know jim if you want
to
well sure carton pointed out that
we've got all these different color
filters and when we take
uh pictures like this panorama in red
green blue
then it's sim can simulate what we see
with our own eyes but
if we use the filters that are a little
in the ultraviolet or a little in the
infrared beyond
i call it superhuman mass kinsey has
superhuman vision
um and we can't look at them in red
green blue so we have to false color
them
kind of like a lot of the pictures you
see from the hubble space telescope
they're taken outside of human
normal vision and they're false colored
and so
you'll start seeing once we start using
those filters
and i know garden's going to do a great
job calibrating them
you'll start seeing these kind of andy
warhol garish views of mars that don't
look like what we'd see it
with our eyes but that look just like
what mascanzi can see with its
superhuman eyes and like kirtan said
that gives us some
sensitivity to different kinds of
rocks and minerals and just color
variations and i think of us as
using the cameras kind of to do triage
you know we
we can sweep this these fields of view
across the whole scene with the
navigation cameras the hazard cameras
and mass cam z
and we're using color differences as a
proxy for
well maybe there's a really interesting
chemistry there maybe there's
interesting minerals there
maybe there's an interesting texture and
and we'll drive over and use all the arm
instruments that we'll be seeing and
hearing a lot about in the weeks to come
use those to get the much more detailed
information
and i know jim you made an incredible uh
storyboard with your teammates and it
really
shows truly how this camera can zoom
you want to take a little tour through
this should we do that yeah let's do it
let's do it
all right well so we're going to start
this is the full version of the panorama
360 degrees it connects on the left and
the right you could wrap it around
uh and it goes right right down to
looking at our feet
out to the horizon and a little bit of
the sky as well so go ahead and
zoom to the first region here we're
going to zoom in
on this panorama all the way behind the
rover this is looking
to the north a little bit northwest
and you can see a couple of different
ridges there's a near
ridge closer to us and then there's
those far mountains
the near ridge closest to us is the the
front
edge of the delta the jezreel crater
delta that
brought us to this site that brought
this rover to this place
and that we're going to eventually drive
over to beyond that those distant
mountains
are the the rim of jezreel crater you
know jezreel has a big hole in the
ground it has these mountainous
uh uh circular uh rim of
of uh mountains that surround us and and
we're seeing them
all in the edges of this uh this
panorama so those are pretty far away
those are three four or five kilometers
away
in the distance but the delta itself is
only about two kilometers a little under
a mile and a half or so
away so it's relatively close the
engineers got us in a beautiful spot
and uh let's let's zoom back out and
just look at a couple of the
features a number of the science folks
on our team
have been looking at these different
areas and zooming in and trying to do
some
instant science and analysis and let's
go to the first
zoomed in region here this is
uh you're transported uh you can see the
resolution of the panorama right we you
know we keep going in there and it's
like wow look at this detail
uh this is uh just a a blocky hill we
think is
a separated remnant maybe of the
original
delta uh maybe the delta was much larger
and it's been eroded away but leaving
these little blocky remnants
behind we see you know some evidence
that it might be more resistive
on its top this is obviously our first
look at it
we're going to be getting much higher
resolution data this is our widest
angle zoom so our lowest resolution
almost on the camera
so we're starting to telephoto in to
these now
over the coming days and weeks and we'll
get much more detail and then of course
to get even more detail we'll drive over
there or
somewhere near there we'll get closer to
these features let's go to the next one
so zoom back out and get a
get a sense of again the the wide scale
right now let's zoom into the next one i
think this is going to be another part
of the delta this is uh farther
uh towards the north and and west part
of the delta
see some again this blocky kind of top
to it there's
faint hints of some layering in here
maybe you know we would expect that from
what we've seen from orbit and from what
we know about
deltas but it's really kind of a tease
because we of course want better
resolution
and lots of folks thinking about what
what could be going on here lots of sort
of geologic comparisons to
what's going on in deltas and other
places on the earth
let's zoom out and look at some other
features that are really close
by some individual rocks and other rocky
regions we'll go to the next one
i think this is going to go to yeah this
is an area pretty close
uh to the rover that's uh been scoured
by the retro rockets coming down
and and delivering the rover on the sky
crane so some of the dust and soil
has been scoured away exposing these
rocks with some
some layers that white rock in there is
about a half a meter
across about a foot and a half across
for scale
and interesting features and textures on
it
we don't know whether these are volcanic
sedimentary
some combination of them we don't have
chemical and mineral data yet but again
the cameras are helping us triage and
identify the places where we want to get
those detailed
chemical and mineral measurements let's
zoom out and go to the next one
got two more here to zoom in on i love
how it
it just you get a real sense of the
resolution
uh on this panorama here we go going to
another
interesting weird little rock this one
is also about
half a meter across about a foot and a
half
across and it is uh informally been
called the harbor seal
and it is a highly eroded probably wind
carved
rock we've seen rocks like this at other
mars landing sites
uh these rocks have been exposed to the
winds of mars for
billions of years and you'd think that
the sand grains
you know gently moving across the
surface wouldn't
do much erosion but if you let them do
that work
for two three billion years
you can create these just fantastic uh
forms
uh in the rocks these are these are
called ventefacts on the earth and we do
see these kind of
wind carved features we think they're
win card features at least we need to
get over and take a closer look i'll get
the high resolution on it
to know uh better and even
more we'll zoom out and zoom back into
one more and these i think are
uh this area which is uh going to be to
the to the right here
is even more enigmatic uh and some of
the most interesting stuff we're looking
at these are
light-toned uh pitted rocks
that again part of the dust and
soil that was covering them has been
blown away
by the uh by the retro rockets hopefully
you've all seen that crate
movie about the crazy structures and the
winds moving
when the retro rockets came down almost
like it was alive just
phenomenal stuff so this was all has all
been kind of cleared off a little bit
and you know are these volcanic rocks
are these
carbonate rocks are these some something
else uh you know they have
coatings on them we don't know we don't
have any chemical data or mineral data
on them yet but boy they're certainly
interesting
and part of the story about what's going
on here is is
uh is going to be told when we get more
detailed
information on these these rocks and
some of the other materials in this area
so let's zoom back out again
and this just gives you a flavor for
what you can do in exploring this
panorama on your own the nasa
photojournal site has released the full
resolution tiff file if you want to
download that it'll take a little while
650 megabytes or so but you want to
wallpaper your bathroom with mars that's
the file to use
highest possible resolution and there
are many of us on the team are just
giddy and spending hours just pouring
through this
place to place it's a lot of fun we've
been more you know years
we've been spending years looking at at
this site in satellite images from orbit
that are like
you know 25 centimeter per pixel which
is amazing from orbit but
you know getting down on the ground and
being able to you know pretty much maybe
soon
know what this all is and puzzle out the
story is just super exciting
very exciting and i'm sure that's a
general reaction from your entire team
i mean we're taking a zoom
tour of the red planet and that
just incredible detail i don't think a
lot of us
ever thought in our lifetime to expect
yeah it's pretty spectacular and and
more is coming
remember this is our lowest resolution
panorama
uh we will get three times
this resolution um and we're starting to
get three times this resolution on
selected targets
in the field and we'll pick that up in
earnest once we come back from the
software transition that's going on now
we're going from the cruise software to
the surface flight software that takes
several days
and so once that process is done we'll
get back to characterizing our cameras
the other instruments will do that
they need to do their calibration their
characterizations
so the whole rover is just sort of
slowly coming alive
slowly turning on as the engineers check
out system after system
we're very lucky to have been turned on
and starting our checkouts very early
and uh and getting all this great stuff
out very quickly
to the public including the raw images
that went into this panorama which had
been
released on the jpl public jpl nasa raw
images public website
and as you might imagine we've got so
many people joining us today
on social media and if you want to have
your questions answered remember to use
the hashtag
countdown to mars so let's get to a few
of your questions out there
we've got a lot of them a youtube viewer
asks
are the masscam z pictures used for
stereo vision
3d mapping of the surface
yes that is a major major goal of what
we want to do and it's an advancement
that we're able to make over the mass
cams on curiosity which elsa and her
team at male and space science systems
operate still every day uh 3 000
odd mars days after landing back in 2012
so that those cameras
which fit on the same mass we have a
copy of that mast on
on perseverance those cameras uh have
one
wide angle left eye and one telephoto
right eye and they take spectacular
pictures they're just amazing you've
seen the pictures from curiosity
the the problem in quotes problem is
it's hard to do stereo
you know you have to do stereo at the
the wide angle scale
so it's low resolution stereo compared
to the telephoto lens and it's just
cumbersome to do it and you need a lot
of telephoto images to fill it
and so it's just not as easy and common
to do 3d stereo
with the mast cams on curiosity so the
innovation that we brought
with our partners at ms cube was to
design this zoom system so we could do
stereo at the wide angle like
we've got here and then all the way to
telephoto
so there's a right eye this is the left
eye this panorama you're seeing here
of mask mz there's a right eye version
of this that's
much of it is still on the rover we're
trying to get it down as quickly as we
can
and once we get all the right eye data
down we'll take the left and the right
and we're going to get a beautiful
stereo view of this terrain
at that scale and we'll be doing that
left right at all of our zoom positions
for everything that we do
and we use that stereo information not
just for
science and the geology and the
topography
but to help our engineering friends and
colleagues who are
driving the rover who need that stereo
vision to do hazard avoidance and
traverse planning to guide our friends
uh on the helicopter team who are trying
to find a safe landing site
uh a take off and landing site for the
for the helicopter
they they need stereo data so mass cam z
can help with that
to guide our folks our friends putting
the arm down and the drill down under
the surface they need stereo data they
can get it from the nav cams
at lower resolution we can give them
even better stereo data with the mass
cam zs so
doing that kind of stereo is a hundred
percent part of our
our goal and we're going to put a lot of
those great stereo products
out for the public to enjoy as well
great jim another technical question
from facebook ira kali asks what is the
transfer weight
rate excuse me bandwidth and speed of
data to the rover
from the earth oh my gosh
do you happen to know that elsa
well i i don't have to know the number
but
one thing that is um interesting my
number that i just heard
the day which is you know we start
really low because we have to make sure
everything is working so you start on
your really safe antennas that have
lower
transfer rates so that's how we started
and we couldn't get very much up or down
that's also why we had to
put our first four days of commands on
the rover beforehand
because we're really starting out we we
wouldn't be able to send it all up in
the beginning on these really low rate
antennas
but very quickly on this mission after
we landed everything was a-okay
and they upped the transmission rates
very quickly
and i just turned one of the mission
managers um yesterday
tell us that at this point in the
mission comparing perseverance to
curiosity
we have about 10 times the amount of
data coming down every day that we did
eight years ago when we landed and
that's thanks to
the systems working really well and also
that we have more orbiters more assets
at mars that can relay our data for us
and get all this data down otherwise we
would not have had
this much data down already
i think the numbers are in the hundreds
of kilobits per second
uh i think that's we could go to the
mega yeah
yeah and christopher has a follow-up to
that question on facebook as well
how much longer does it take to receive
mass cam
z data due to the larger data sets
um yeah that's a great that's a great
question
that's a great question and it's it's a
little complicated because
we're not in real time contact with the
rover
you know when elsa said it takes a day
to get the commands there and a day to
get back it's not because it's a day at
the speed of light it's because it's a
day on our
work calendar right it's because we
communicate
we send the commands up to the rover
once per
approximately once per birthday once per
mars day in the morning when the rover
wakes up
first thing it does it listens hey
eric's going to call me with my to-do
list today
and radio that up the deep space network
that nasa runs
gets its command list and then we're out
of contact with it and it's just
executing all those commands take these
pictures
test that instrument turn on this heater
wiggle the wheels drive two meters
forward whatever it's just a long to do
list with time stamps
it's doing it on its own and then near
the end of its day
one of the orbiters nasa or the european
orbiter comes overhead and rover relays
its
results back through that orbiter and
then back to the earth and sometimes it
comes very quickly sometimes there's a
little bit of a delay
but the end result is we're really
getting a big pile of data
once a day maybe twice a day sometimes
in the middle of the mars night we get
one of those orbiter passes as well
uh and so it's it's not we're not
joysticking or not in real time contact
but at least in the first part of this
mission almost all those bits of ones
and zeros coming back to us have been
images the videos that you saw
these spectacular panoramas lots of
engineering data and telemetry but
but the imaging data is the vast
majority of that stream of
radio signal
all right let's turn to the freezing
cold nights
of mars taran on facebook
asks will perseverance send in a night
landscape shot um
well yeah yeah absolutely
what i what i really encourage people to
do is imagine that you're the camera
on mars because our mass is up and
actually the mass is that about six feet
so as we look around it's almost like
you're standing there yourself looking
around
and they are visible cameras um
they're primarily in the same wavelength
that you can see with your eyes and so
if you're there at night on mars how
much could you see
well it's really dark so we can't see a
whole lot
and that's that's where we're at we're
not going to take images at night
for that reason um and also because it's
extremely cold
i mean i was just looking at
temperatures the other day we get down
to minus
80 degrees celsius on our cameras and we
do have heaters on board we use them
even in the morning or later in the
afternoon if we need when we need to we
use the heaters
but that much energy to heat us up that
much in the middle of the night that
would just be prohibitive
so you've got two things against you got
no light and you got too cold of a
temperature
so we generally don't do it except for a
few
um a few occasions when we might be
looking
up into the sky and doing that at night
time
but we do have to set it up beforehand
again we don't want to heat everything
up
it's the cameras it's the mask the
massive mask that you saw
that has to be heated as well so you
want to set it up beforehand so all you
have to do is open the shutter to take
the image
and then be done with your job i'll i'll
just add that you know
you're absolute that's a great
description elsa and um
you know the science goals of our
mission are are focused on
geology mineralogy chemistry also
atmospheric science typically daytime
but the weather station the meta weather
station will be measuring nighttime
temperatures and pressures and all that
kind of stuff so
for imaging it's difficult at night
these are
these are cameras not telescopes right
it's not like taking your
big light bucket telescope out in the
yard and collecting
faint signals these are just cameras so
you know if you just
point and shoot with your iphone or your
android phone it's it's hard to get
deep space astrophotography kind of data
out of that so we can see bright stars
we can see phobos and deimos the moons
of mars
and we'll do some of that science we'll
do some of that nighttime science it
helps us understand the atmosphere and
the moons themselves
and it's sort of great bonus science if
we have the power
to run the heaters if we have the power
to run the cameras
uh if there's scientific questions and
scientific interests that we can direct
at it we'll do that and we'll also i i
predict i mean nothing is formally
planned but
i predict we will do some relatively fun
kind of things like take some pictures
of the earth
you know take this has been done on
previous rover and lander missions uh we
will
take what you know these are the
ultimate selfies right everybody on the
earth in that one
pale blue dot in the sky so we'll
probably do some
sort of fun stuff like that too and
speaking of
atmospheric science glenn on facebook
asked does condensation form
at night on mars kjaert is the physicist
so he should take that question
well it it happens um probably not that
much here
because we're close to the equator and
there's not that much moisture
there's actually some pretty amazing
images from viking
with frost on the ground so
it happens but it will be frost connings
condensating because the uh
the atmosphere is so thin that when
that the water can can be a gas or it
can be
ice a frost but it cannot be liquid
and so it will go to frost on the ground
and then it will go straight back up in
the atmosphere but you can get
like especially if you're not on the
equator or close to the equator like we
are
you can get like a frosty morning that
uh like you can get
here on earth and rachel on facebook
asks how do you deal with dust on the
lenses
well that's a great question uh i get i
get that question every single time
that's
that's a wonderful question um we
actually uh
we don't do a lot about it actually we
we mitigate
mitigate we we prevent uh dust from
collecting on the lens by
pointing the cameras down when we're not
using them that that
end of the mass we just point it down
and that
that prevents the dust that's always
falling gently out of the atmosphere
from
collecting on our lenses but we know
that dust is going to collect on our
lenses
when when we're imaging and especially
up at the sky and all that
we can't point down all the time and we
don't have any little wiper blades or
anything like that
no way to no covers to to protect them
so we just we know that the lenses are
going to get a little bit dusty over
time
and and sort of two things uh one if any
anybody who wears glasses i wear glasses
uh contacts but i also wear glasses
you take your glasses off and just look
at them elsa look at your glasses
they're probably kind of
filthy dirty right they've got dust all
over them and specks and hair
but you put them on and you can still
see through them right and it's
it's not that bad you get a little bit
of dust
and so we can live with that and if it
does get a little thicker we can correct
for that with our calibration
that curtain and others are working on
and secondly
what we've discovered in previous
missions
is that once in a while the winds of
mars come and they
blow the dust off off the deck of the
rover
off the calibration targets off the
lenses
and uh so mars has been actually pretty
helpful
in past missions and keeping our our
lenses clean but
our our prevention is really kind of
passive
and just point them down
i'll add a little something to that
because
exactly this reason of the dust is why
we had to get going
really quickly without imaging we wanted
to take images as soon as we
could of a clean rover deck well as
curtin can attest to it wasn't entirely
clean because you know all the dust that
was kicked up
but specifically for carton and the
other scientists
on our team jim being another um big
proponent of this
we wanted to look at the deck as as
cleanly as we could
so we can compare that to all the data
that comes after
and that was one of the big reasons we
were allowed to image as
early as we did and in fact even the day
before we imaged this one
we took um we took a huge amount of
calibration target data and um that was
really so that
the calibration could compare to that
for the rest of the mission and we'll
continue to do that
and monitor you know take images on a
regular basis to monitor the dust
that's accumulating and it's my
understanding curtin that there's some
special places on the cal target that
deals with dust
you can put up slightly imitate
so it's obviously a problem for the
calibration target too that and that
is always facing upwards and dust will
drizzle on them
no um slide a the major
spidey um so they get they will
gradually
get dusty and sometimes the dust will
get blown off a little bit and they will
get
that's the one um and actually right at
landing there's
a bunch of dust that gets kicked up by
the rockets right
we wanted to image it right after
landings as quickly as possible
that's the cleanest it's ever going to
be um
but it has these you can see how the
dust is rings around the patches
and that's because we build in these
very strong
hollow cylinder magnets that are sitting
right underneath those surfaces
and they attract the dust to where the
magnet is but in the middle the magnet
is not
and that area is kept fairly clean of
dust
and that will work also for the dust in
the martian atmosphere
it works because there's iron in the
dust both in this dust and in the dust
that comes drizzling down from the
atmosphere so those magnets are going to
keep those little areas
pretty much clean of dust and those
colors are going to be
like they were in the lab when we
measured them and and we're going to be
trusting them still but another thing is
that
on other parts of the calibration target
it will gradually get dusty and we will
be able to monitor that and that's
actually kind of a little extra
um a piece of of a meteorological data
because we can sort of tell when the
dust is falling and when it gets blown
off and it's like a seasonal thing on
mars
i'll i'll mention that uh curtin wrote a
great
blog piece on our public website in
marina we'll give you the address at the
end
all about this target and all about the
magnets and
that why the colors were chosen and the
little messages and
and vignettes and all that and the the
sort of
uh artistic elements that we were able
to
put on this with help from the planetary
society and mark gilberto is an artist
who works with
with the society and a small group of us
on the team so
encourage folks to check out curtin's uh
article that's on our website
and speaking of that for kiara 10 je
bruce on twitter wants to know where he
can get his hands on one of those
sundials
and can you tell us more about the
sundial
maybe i should start a company and just
crank him out yes
we have a few spears when you send an
instrument you have to build a flight
spear
in case something goes wrong with the
instrument before you launch
so you actually have two flight spears
they're not for sale
and we have a few extra sort of test
units
um but it's only a little handful and
they'll probably wind up in museums
where you might be able to see them
jim has a 3d printed version there and
we we do
we do have 3d print files that maybe
we'll put out at some point
we should put the 3d print files on our
public website if you're willing to do
it yeah we could do that yeah
sure absolutely this just gives you a
sense of scale this is full size yep so
yep there it is and we did have uh you
mentioned museums we had the
the flight spare for the spirit and
opportunity cal target
was on display in the smithsonian
special exhibit about those rovers so
lots of people put their eyes on that
one
yeah i remember i went there jim and i i
wrote that i
i just came back from standing in the in
the in the
august presence of the of the apollo 11
command module and you wrote back how
about the august presence of the
spear pancan kel target yes
and i said that was a flight spear it
wasn't the flight culture yeah
anyway well as a as a meteorologist we
as a meteorologist we're getting tons of
weather questions so i'm really excited
about that
everyone is very excited talking about
the weather on mars
on social media this afternoon chopra on
facebook
asks any storms expected there and how
do you manage them
and how would they affect the mass cam z
yeah i mean we don't manage the weather
we do not
uh absolutely uh but uh
you know the the the great thing about
the fact that we've had 60 years of
exploring mars with
flybys orbiters landers and rovers is
that
we really know a lot about the weather
and it is
very repeatable from year to year not
precisely
some years are different some years have
these big dust storms that cover the
whole planet we don't really understand
why those form in some years not others
but in general
you know everywhere on mars has a dusty
season and a less dusty season
and there's always small dust storms all
the time and
sometimes it's cloudy and with water ice
clouds and sometimes it's not but we
understand a lot about those patterns
from these previous
missions and so you know we landed at a
time that's not
particularly problematic for dust storms
but there will come a time when there
will be more of an issue for dust it's
not
so much of a concern for perseverance
and curiosity nuclear-powered rovers as
opposed to the solar-powered rovers
spirit
opportunity and solar-powered missions
like insight
uh you know the ultimately it was mars
dust
and dust storms that killed both spirit
and opportunity because of the dust
settling on those
solar panels and the dust darkening the
sky
and cutting off their solar power so we
we care about the way it changes
temperatures we care about the way it
could
mess up our lenses so we do follow it
track it and pay attention to it but
honestly we mostly care about it
scientifically because it's a really
interesting part of the weather
and we're trying to learn as much as we
can about the weather on mars so that
once future astronauts and settlers go
there within the next few decades
they'll have a really good understanding
of what to expect and when at different
times a year
elsa and then there's also a little
story about how we captured some sand in
the uh
cameras with curiosity that gave us a
nice lesson learned for
for this mission so what happened was
during dust storms on mars
um sand would deposit we have these
long lens covers that keep
straight light from coming into our
images well they're also really good at
trapping
small small small amounts of sand
and we didn't even think about this
um until one day when we were looking
up at the skies we talked about and we
take images you know at different angles
to look at the atmosphere
and we notice there's some there seems
to be something off there's definitely
something off in these measurements
and we looked into it further and we
compared you know over time
how did this exhibit itself and uh
mark lemon who's one of our most
prominent atmospheric scientists
looked at his data as well and we
realized there's something in front
there is absolutely something in front
so we took some experiments
and we determined that yes indeed when
you go up
and when you go down it looks different
just very
um proof
really strong indicators we say in the
scientific
world um that we had sand inside the
lenses
well you can't just go up there and sort
of shake it out right
that that's not how it works um so we
still have a little of it um
inside the the covers on curiosity and
what we learned from that was on these
cameras
we drilled a little tiny hole in the
enclosure
so that if we do get sand inside this
time it will trickle out on its own
and we won't have this problem yep
little drain holes
good lesson from curiosity yeah it's
actually kind of amazing that little
sand grains
are hopping across the surface and
bouncing up
six feet and going into the front
of our the lenses are set back a little
bit there's like a sun shade a baffle so
there's a little bit of volume there
and on on curiosity they're hopping up
in there and getting in there it's
totally
surprising okay the storms are not
the storms you know the winds can be
high speed but the answer is so thin
that the power in them is not very high
it's not like it's going to
jiggle the rover or tip it over or
anything like that
but it can still move sand and obviously
dust but but it's kind of surprising how
much it can move sand even though it's
such a thin atmosphere yeah it's like
that carved rock
you know how long it took to do that you
know that a lot of people have seen the
movie the martian
and there's that scene in the beginning
with this violent storm you know
i mean it's it's a dramatic and fun
scene but it's science fiction i mean
it's nothing like that i mean
the wind speeds can be very high but it
would be like somebody
blowing up you know feathers by you
it would feel just so light it's so thin
but it moves sand and dust very
efficiently
and you're constantly looking towards
the future and so dbl on twitch
asked what changes have you made to the
rover design to better suit the
conditions of mars which i think elsa
just answered with adding those holes so
that you are able to to get that dust
off so we'll move on to harry on twitter
who's asking could you please describe
the software you're using to stitch
together that panorama
is it custom software developed in-house
or using
commercial software like lightroom or
photoshop
if custom what operating system is used
great question yeah do you want to start
gym or you want me to take it
uh you start and i'll finish okay sounds
great
so could we have that picture again with
the frames on it it was a second
i think it was number five yes perfect
that is such a great depiction of
what my life what our team's life looks
like um
on a daily basis this is homecoming
software
as i mentioned before john proton wrote
it he was actually
um way back on murr going back
now almost 20 years he was one of the
operators that would do commanding
and then realized at one point you know
what i can do this software much better
than anything that's commercially
available
anything that people have thought of
because he did the job and then he took
his software
programming skills put the two together
and came up with this tool and it
it truly is um the only
uh software of its kind on this planet
so it's specifically customized for
um visualizing imaging and
this is just one way of um looking at it
but there's a lot of details that goes
into it that's at our fingertips
um the distances to each
part of the image what the focus would
be that would correspond to it there's
just a tremendous amount of
power behind it so we're extremely
grateful to have this and in fact it's
thanks to jim
working on pan cam with john and then we
did a beta version for
um mass cam on msl that we've been
running now for years
all of it with the thought that we would
get this tool
for this mission with these cameras and
it is spectacularly paid off it is
exactly
i mean it's more than i could even
imagine you know um
chris and i were talking the other day
one of my ops engineers and
he was just laughing he's like i cannot
believe this piece of software i don't i
don't even know everything to do with it
yet i can't wait till we can explore it
more and we all feel like that
it's it's amazing so it's it's there's a
lot of custom
homegrown software but we also do
occasionally use
photoshop or those kinds of commercial
tools uh to
to finish some of the processing and
stitching so it's it's a mix
and like oh sorry go ahead go ahead
yeah i wanted to finish up on the
question the operating systems
um we really use all kinds um we're
using
um some of my team runs on max we also
have some dells
we use linux and um just throughout
we are a team of hundreds of scientists
and engineers if you count them all up
there's probably thousands
and we use all kinds of tools
make them all work together our tools
that we run for the mission
that all of us run have to run on all
those um you know well-known platforms
yep and there's all kinds of programming
in c
python matlab idl i got some old fortran
stuff that i can still use
you know it's it's a it's a real
wide array of programming not only a
wide array of programming
but it's a village and thank you so much
for everyone's questions out there on
social media so many of you joined us
today
and we'll try to answer some of your
questions as we progress through the
rest of the day and tomorrow but
thank you most of all to jim elsa and
kiarten for joining me this afternoon
it's been a lot of fun and we just have
to thank all of our teammates
on the masscam z team on the entire
rover team the nasa
jpl team the folks who built the rocket
the folks who got through kova to get us
to the launch pad
i mean what an incredible team thousands
of people
involved in ultimately getting to this
kind of
this kind of spectacular imaging yeah
thanks for having me so much yes thanks
for having us
oh thank you so much we can't wait to
see the rest of the panoramas now for
the latest on the mission
follow at nasa persevere on both twitter
and facebook
and you can also take a deeper dive at
the mission's website
mars.nasa.gov
perseverance and as jim mentioned
there's lots of information
about the mass cam z instrument on the
website
mastcamz.asu.edu
and the very latest images can be found
at
mars.nasa.gov
mars2020 slash multimedia
slash raw hyphen images
a lot of great feasts for the eyes as
jim likes to put it
now thanks so much for watching this
afternoon and go
perseverance
you